moi ma vision est claire c'est 1905 et
rien que 1905
je ne souhaite pas qu'on change la loi
de 1905 et ce qu'elle représente et ce
qu'elle permet de préserver ma question
n'est pas de savoir si c'est bien ou pas
bien que une jeune fille met le voile au
pas le voile dans la rue c'est pas la
question que de laquelle doit répondre
présent dans le public c'est la question
de savoir si elle est libre de le faire
ou pas smadja il n'a pas le courage
d'ouvrir ce dossier président il a
raison de ne pas l'ouvrir
la loi de 1905 est une loi qui maintient
un équilibre fragile entre la protection
des cultes et le fait que les cultes ne
doivent jamais intervenir dans la
décision publique
cet équilibre là il faut absolument le
préserver c'est un des fondements de la
république et c'est vrai que il y a
quelques mois
emmanuel macron lors d'un discours d'une
intervention devant la conférence des
évêques de france
au collège des bernardins à paris je
crois que c'était au mois d'avril
il avait dit quelque chose qui avaient
beaucoup troublé il avait dit le lien
s'est abîmé entre l'église et l'état et
nous devons le réparer je cite quasiment
cdu mot-à-mot hélas avait beaucoup
troublé par ce que il faisait référence
à quoi quand il parlait du lien abîmé
entre l'église et l'état
il faisait référence à la loi qui a
légalisé le mariage pour tous il faisait
référence à sa propre proposition dans
son programme de légaliser
la pma et là c'est vrai que beaucoup ont
considéré qu' il y avait une brèche dans
une vision acquise
je pense de la laïcité alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui rétabli les choses en disant
finalement on ne touchera pas à la loi
de 1905
oui c'est finalement c'est plutôt une
bonne chose oui une bonne chose selon
vous alexis une occasion manquée non pas
du tout effectivement il y avait le
projet de revoir la loi de 905 pas du
tout pour les catholiques
il est allé raconter des blagues est
allé passer la main dans le dos des
catholiques pour en fait réviser la loi
de fiances un jour marcher au marché
comme des idiots qui peut leur passer la
main dans le dos lors de votre le lien
tout ça mais il n'y avait rien à faire
vous avez absolument raison une personne
demande qu'on répare aucun lien c'était
pas ça le sujet le sujet c'était
vis-à-vis de l'islam pour financer les
mosquées et former les imams
c'était son programme présidentiel et il
s'est rendu compte
heureusement dieu soit loué que c'était
que c'était que c'était une erreur ou
que c'était politiquement trop compliqué
que ça lui procurait plus dormi que
davantage et donc il y renonce
il renonce cette espèce d'idiot ci qui
consiste à dire de la même façon qu'il a
fallu des siècles à la religion
catholique pour s'adapter la laïcité la
religion musulmane pour peu qu'on
s'adapte et qu'on fasse les efforts asus
est nécessaire ça ne se fera le même
chemin tous at il enfin tout ça ne tient
pas debout
d'abord ce que la religion musulmane au
sens rémi brague explique très bien
expliqué encore hier soir d'une
conférence du filet au n'est pas une
religion comme la religion catholique
c'est un système juridique global et
donc dire qu'elle doit se retirer de la
société n'a pas de sens c'est destiné à
régir la société l'islam premièrement et
deuxièmement dire on va former des imams
pour qu'ils interprètent différemment le
coran c'est bien gentil de le problème
c'est qu'ils n'ont aucun imam a le droit
d'interpréter le coran puisque le grand
a été dicté par dieu donc c'était ça
l'idée
il y renonce tant mieux est-ce qu'il
fallait pas christophe devaux quand même
envisager de retirer l
enfin d'essayer d'organiser cet islam de
france aujourd'hui soumis à des
influences étrangères à des financements
étrangers
c'est un gros problème à les
financements étrangers mais ça peut se
régler par d'autres besoins pas besoin
de toucher à la loi nul y'a pas voilà
que demain il ya besoin de toucher à la
loi de 1905
moi je crois que de façon plus générale
sur ce sujet comme sur tant d'autres ont
parlé des retraites je vous arrête je
vais pas besoin de toucher à la loi de
1905 mais un dans le projet de réforme
il y avait la possibilité pour les
cultes de se financer par exemple en
utilisant leur patrimoine immobilier
c'était c'était une action et fabien
technique mais c'est vrai que c'était
quand on dit pas besoin de toucher s'il
fallait toucher parce que c'était passé
du culte du culturel officiel d'arrêt
mais je crois qu'il y aura pas de grande
réforme pour une raison d'abord parce
que beaucoup d intellectuels qui
l'écoutaient sont très très rétif sur
cette question de laïcité et peut-être
beaucoup plus que qu'il ya quelques
années
donc il ya un risque pour emmanuel
macron et je pense que après avoir une
telle de crise sociale qui comme vous
l'avez rappelé n'est pas terminé il va
on part en plus se taper une crise
sociétale en souvient ce que ça a pu
faire à françois hollande urgent dates
seront donc à mon avis sur ce sujet
comme sur d'autres car la pma tous à gpa
toutes ces réformes je nous dire elle ne
se feront peut-être en tout cas pas tout
de suite peut-être jamais pendant le
quinquennat est toute la question qui va
se poser à l'issue du grand débat et qui
restent sur la table
est-ce que emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement ont encore une capacité de
réformer quoi que ce soit la question
n'est pas tranchée à la fois c'est une
bonne chose d'avoir renoncé pour
l'instant à tout changement est à la
fois il est très clair que la plaie est
toujours ouverte
de ce côté là il est très clair que
cette loi 1905 elle était là pour
maintenir la religion dans le domaine
privé et comme l'a bien souligné
emmanuel macron pour garantir la liberté
de choix quelque sorte et là on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que dans la situation
dans laquelle on est face à l'islam
radical
la loi de 1905 leur permet en réalité un
développement et une religion qui
n'avions pas renoncer à l'objectif
théocratique qui est extrêmement
clairement annoncé c'est à dire c'est la
primauté de la loi est au coran et la
loi est extrêmement
faut dire claire à ce moment là dans
l'objectif de la façon dont on veut que
la société soit gérée donc à un moment
donné où la neutralité sur laquelle ça
soit ça soit la loi de 1905 qui est de
dire on a des religions qui acceptent de
ne pas jouer le rôle politique parce que
c'était ça en 1905
c'était une sorte de trait dans dix ans
voilà là l'église catholique accepte et
parfaitement de rester dans son rôle
privé on avait cette possibilité d'
équilibre aujourd'hui cet équilibre il
est profondément remise en cause
donc on n'a malheureusement pas le début
d'une réponse pour l'instant donc c'est
plus une défaite face à il était encore
probablement tôt parce que on n'a pas la
réflexion assez mûr pour arriver à agir
j'ai l'impression il faut quand même le
taux de service que depuis le début de
son quinquennat
emmanuel macron a quand même une
tendance assez naturelle à flatter les
religions quelles qu'elles soient
l'islam la religion catholique le
judaïsme
c'est quelque chose qui fait assez
souvent et il le fait parce que je pense
que d'une certaine manière ils regardent
le modèle anglo saxon et que le modèle
anglo saxon l'intéressent je pense que
c'est une erreur profonde et que
précisément flatter les religions c'est
c'est accepter qu'elle joue un rôle
qu'elles n'ont pas aujourd'hui dans la
prise de décision publique et dans la
prise de décision politique
à ce propos je vous donne la parole de
suite alexis mais à un autre extrait de
discours d' emmanuel macron hier à
l'elysée vous allez voir une question du
burkini que c'était bien la différence
justement entre le culturel et cultuel
on écoute il y à un sujet avec l'islam
qui est qu'est multiples facettes parce
que il y a certains ont parlé d'
insécurité culturel mais il y avait au
fond dans notre pays quelque chose qui
se vit où on mélange le fait cultuelle
le fait culturel le fait migratoire et
tout ça s'entremêlant on va dire que ça
s'écraserait sur la laïcité ensemble
quand on a des débats sur le burqini ou
que sais-je
ça n'a rien à voir avec la laïcité c'est
pas cultuelle si on pousse la réflexion
à ceux à cette aune là on n'aurait pas
fait la loi sur les signes ostentatoires
à l'école
non mais je pense que il a eu la
tentation comme d'autres et comme
sarkozy avant lui d'ailleurs cette
tentation
bonapartiste au sens de bona pas
d'organiser un islam modéré on va à fond
son aîné dé pas de rechange et loi 1905
pour la durcir sur l'université de de
changer de 1905 pour l'assouplir en
contrepartie de cet assouplissement
d'obtenir un une modération de l'islam
en discutant avec des responsables d'un
islam de france sarkozy avait fait avait
eu exactement la même idée ça avait été
un échec cuisant
car dès qu'on devait entendre qu'on
discute avec les uns d'autres plus
radicaux arrive derrière et ça échoue il
manque ablement et donc il a eu cette
idée là qui effectivement s'inscrit sans
doute lui aussi pour lui dans un humour
imaginaire anglo saxons c'est à dire
d'idées qui est des communautés et qu'on
puisse discuter toutes ces communautés
et c'est bien bas après tout discutons
avec les musulmans ils vont s'organiser
ça se passera bien et ils sortiront de
leurs de l'idée que l'islam doit
régenter la société mais le problème
c'est que ces intrinsèque c'est
consubstantiel islam c'est le principe
de l'islam et la société bon en tout cas
toujours cette île qui s'est dit que ça
valait pas le coup de tenter cette
affaire là il y renoncer et quand il dit
le burqini n'a rien à voir avec la
laïcité
voilà ça devient exclusion un peu trop
intellectuel pour moi je voulais en
réjouis je exactement j'ai du mal à
comprendre et surtout j'ai du mal à voir
quelle est la décision politique qui
pourraient découler de ce constat que ce
que je comprends pas en fait hein donc
puisqu'il est quand même préciser que le
burqini et est porté pour des raisons
non pas cul turelle mais cultuelle
puisque le burkini n'est pas une un
vêtement traditionnel ça ce serait un
non sens culturel dans aucun pays
vous connaissez le burqini ailleurs ça a
été complètement une invention pour des
raisons pressante
je crois que le vrai problème il vient
du fait que l'islam depuis 20 ans c'est
très simple on prend tous tous les faits
divers tous les chiffres dans en
occident c'est profondément durci sous
l'effet de l'influent salafistes porté
par les pétrodollars du qatar et de
l'arabie séoudite faudrait appeler les
choses telles quelles donc on a une
version de l'islam on ne connaît d'autre
moi je connais d'autres connaissent et
nous
on a pas mal de version de l'islam y en
a même qui sont assez on va dire
pacifique en matière de politique c'est
à dire qu'ils interviennent peu dans le
domaine politique notamment même une des
versions salafistes vont en ce sens mais
nous on a une version quand même qui est
très influencé par les frères musulmans
c'est à dire d'un islam politique et qui
depuis 20 ans gagne des points parce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui par des
puissances qui ont des moyens et qui
sont vous le voyez pas seulement
présente dans les mosquées mais aussi
dans les stades de football par exemple
donc nous avons nous sommes en position
de faiblesse vis-à-vis d'un certain
teddy souffler un peu moins
généralisateur et je pense que c'est ça
qui va être le plus dur ça va être de
négocier avec un islam avec cet islam là
qui ne veut pas négocier cet islam là
quelques-unes de vos réactions sur ce
sujet d'abord à la question emmanuel
macron at il raison de ne pas vouloir
changer la loi de 1905
vous êtes une importante majorité 79%
d'entre vous disent que oui il a raison
de ne pas y toucher
monsieur babineau nous dit monsieur
babineau et la macro a raison de ne pas
ouvrir ce dossier surtout si c'est pour
dénaturer la loi et montrait du doigt
une religion en particulier et va et
victis la laïcité française est dépassée
c'est une conception bien française fait
pour les chrétiens et des athées
culturellement chrétiens alors un sujet
religieux mais un tout autre sujet quand
même c'est celui donc de cardinal
barbarin le pape françois n'a pas
accepté la démission du cardinal
barbarin démission que le cardinal lui a
présenté hier à rome après avoir été
condamné à six mois de prison avec
sursis par un tribunal de lyon et comme
l'a révélé hier notre journaliste jean
marie guénois le pape a décidé
d'attendre que la justice suive son
cours et que l'appel formé contre ce
jugement soit examinée en attendant
l'archevêque de lyon se mettra quelques
temps en retrait de ses fonctions
c'est une sage décision du pape olivier
babeau j'ai du mal a commenté la
décision du pape ils pas censés être
infaillible d'ailleurs pas sur ces
sujets